what's going on reject nation happy
Monday before going into this I want to
say happy birthday to fellow patronage
act Matthew beer happy birthday to you
but I put out a post on patreon saying
how much we love you your spirit your
knowledge your humor
everything about you has been such a
delight to get to know you over 2017 and
we're still getting to know you even
more right now and you're supposed to be
coming out to California around the
April time you best believe we'll kick
it sometime buddy we love you and wish
you were coming to our live Schmo down
match by the way live Schmo down match
keep a lookout for that March 15th
tickets available now before going into
this story which is about how the
Naughty Dog director whose name is Neil
druckmann he was giving updates on the
Uncharted and Last of Us movies
Uncharted was a series that I actually
started playing pre ad pocalypse and I
got to chapter 13 ad pocalypse kicked in
and I just sort of stopped playing the
game so I really have to pick it up last
week I just randomly started playing The
Last of Us and I've been up really late
at night playing this game it's the
first game in many many many years where
I am truly addicted to playing it that I
just want to get to the evening so I can
chill out and continue playing this game
I love it I think I'm halfway through it
now I honestly think it'll be the first
game I finish so I came across this
article I thought was really interesting
that just happened to come out today the
Naughty Dog creative director Neil
druckmann
was speaking about the Uncharted movie
and the Last of Us movie so here's the
first part the in charted movie in
regards to the one that Tom Hollands
gonna be starring in and supposedly
directed by Shawn Levy where it's about
a young Nathan Drake didn't sound too
appealing to me but here's what he had
to say the Uncharted movie yeah we've
had some conversations with Shawn Levy
and he's really passionate gets it and I
think he understands where we're at
we've kind of evolved our feelings
towards these kind of adaptations over
the years we used to just be excited oh
my god movies are looking at us there
could be an in charter movie on the
screen then as more time passes on we're
not excited about a different adaptation
of the story we told because we feel
like we've already told that story very
well cinematically so I don't know what
else you could bring to it
levy wanting to tell a different story
than the main four adventures with
potentially young Nathan Drake that
fills in the gaps I think it's a lot
more interesting than trying to retell
uncharted one two three and four and
speaking of the last of us which Sam
Raimi was producing he said that even I
worked on the script for the Last of Us
film which was a direct adaptation and
now having some separation from it I
look back and I'm like I don't want that
movie to be made this was fascinating to
hear it from a creative director from
the videogame standpoint you know a lot
of times we see these video game movies
and when I first heard about the
Uncharted movie with Tom Holland I was
like does anyone really want that I
don't want that I'd rather just see a
direct adaptation of Uncharted even
playing The Last of Us I was thinking
there's a way you could trim this down
to make it into a movie or even do TV
shows it might be like an insanely huge
budget for a TV show with a lot more
development being had a TV with a lot of
directors and actors going to TV they're
throwing a lot more budgets at TV so I
wouldn't be surprised if we start
getting some video games adapted in TV
series formats because of my personal
opinion I feel like most video game
adaptations would probably work best
under a TV adaptation format but hearing
what he had to say here especially
coming from the video game directors
perspective maybe he has a point
actually if you're gonna adapt a video
game is there really a point in adapting
it directly is there a point doing a
direct adaptation of any of the
Uncharted games or the Last of Us game
it's funny to hear him talk about how he
worked on the last of a script himself
and now looking back or not he's like no
I don't want that to be made because he
has a strong point video games like
Uncharted like Last of Us like Metal
Gear Solid are so cinematic already that
they put a lot of effort and a lot of
time into their script their cutscenes
telling a really gripping enticing story
it's probably best to just keep this
story that they're telling in the video
game the way it's meant to be done
because I've taken time to watch the
cutscenes like when it came to the tomb
raider movie trailer coming out I hadn't
played the game I didn't have time to so
I just took time one night to watch all
the cutscenes that had a little bit of
gameplay in there and it's primarily
cutscenes and watching I'm like I
yeah but the whole story is I feel the
whole thing and this felt like I just
watched the movie I did the same thing
with the unjustice game so now when I go
to play on Jeff injustice with friends
I'm just playing the game universes mode
but I've seen all the cutscenes I know
the whole story now behind the first
injustice there's a really good point
he's making here which is you don't need
to make the movie when hey you could
just play the game and get the movie
itself from there and it's more
interactive and more fun and a lot of
the times when you try to do direct
adaptations of the games itself do you
try to do like the gameplay moments it
kind of makes you wish you were playing
the actual game itself I remember when I
was watching the doom a movie they had
this shot that seemed cool at first
where it's all through first person
point of view a halfway through that
shot I remember thinking I wish I was
just playing the game now instead cuz
that feels like it would be a lot more
fun so then it goes through the argument
well why don't you just mainly stick to
adapting this thing the the parts that
were cinematic adapting the cutscenes
and bringing them into real life but
graphics nowadays are so good especially
something like The Last of Us where the
attention to detail the cutscenes is
practically like you're watching real
life so there would be no point to doing
it down as this really get me excited
for an uncharted movie about a young
Nathan Drake played by Tom Holland not
really but now that I get this guy's
perspective it makes me a lot more
intrigued it makes me go oh well I'm
definitely gonna give the movie a chance
now I don't know if they're gonna be
making this movie anytime soon I mean
infinity Wars coming out and then
spider-man homecoming 2 supposed to
start filming soon so they stopped Tom
Hollands schedule I don't know if the
dude would even have the time to make it
this year probably have to wait till
2019 to film it hearing what this
director had to say it has swayed me
more into that idea that arena because
for the longest time I've been saying if
you're gonna do direct adaptations make
a TV show so that way you can expand it
and include everything as well like the
best comparison would have to be
something like Game of Thrones where
there's like a specific amount of books
and they adapt the books but then they
really expanded and really create a
whole bunch of new stuff and go beyond
what the books do and I feel that's
something you can do with a lot of these
video game franchises The Last of Us was
definitely something we're out when I
play it I'm thinking this could be a
movie but it already feels so much like
a movie and I think that's why it's so
engrossing after playing The Last of Us
and hearing this
like well maybe you can actually do one
of those in between stories the problem
that occurs with that though is I think
if you were to do a Last of Us movie
you'd want to see Joel and Ellie both in
the film and I was thinking well the
only big gap is the 20-year gap after
the beginning of the Last of Us and then
it does like a 20-year jump I think and
then you get into the story eventually
with Ellie and Joel on this mission but
in the Last of Us game it's when Joel
and Ellie are meeting each other for the
first time so I don't really see how you
could include Ellie if you and if you
just did a Joel story within that 20
year gap or you did a younger Ellie
story which I don't know would be very
enticing there's all these other
characters that you get teases of it and
make appearances in the game that you
could probably do stories on but if
you're gonna do a video game adaptation
it would probably have to be something
more along the lines of what they're
planning for Uncharted which is you take
the main character in this case for
Lasell is Joel and you probably do a
story in between that 20-year gap tour
in when the apocalypse was really
starting to come into fruition curious
to see what you guys have to say about
it would you guys prefer that they do
direct video game adaptations of the
film's in which case you would have to
cut out a lot it condense it into two
hours which rather see TV shows made of
these video games or would you rather
than do what they're planning on doing
when Naughty Dog director's planning on
doing which is doing movies that fill in
the gaps so to speak put your comments
down below and happy birthday Matt beer
love you buddy can't wait to see you
this year subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification bell again
notified every time one of our videos is
up and check out our patreon a
full-length music video and TV show
reactions over their exclusive q and a's
check it out